Please put your hands together.
Welcome to the stage Peter Godfrey Smith.
Okay.
This talk will be a fast underwater to of animal evolution.
Uh,
and in particular the evolution of the mind.
The first fact here I think is the fact that the mind evolved in the sea.
This idea has,
uh,
several sides to it.
Firstly,
just the fact that for all the early stages,
that first and crucial period until about 400 million years ago,
just about all life and all animal life was in the sea.
That was the context.
And in that period before life on land,
most of the essentials were laid down.
So the evolution of animals themselves,
the evolution of nervous systems and then brains,
the evolution of complex sensors such as eyes.
And if bodies that can act in complex ways and to some extent all the rest is
fine tuning.
Now,
I'm not saying that everything was in place before we came up on land.
Mammals certainly have special features as to humans,
but the basics are in place.
And the question then arises is whether what was in place included those aspects
of the mind that philosophers have found most mysterious,
subjective experience and consciousness.
Now this is a famously difficult question,
but I think we can work towards answering it.
And I think the answer to the question is yes.
Now one more aspect to the idea that the mind evolved in the sea,
uh,
is related to that last point.
So when you think about how it's even possible for a physical system to have
mental states,
especially experiences,
part of what makes this problem seems so hard,
I think so hard that people despair of it is the fact that people have a
particular picture of the physical,
uh,
in their heads when they think about this aspect of the problem.
They have a kind of dry land macroscopic,
a picture of the physical and how physical things interact or perhaps they have
in mind the particular kinds of interaction you find within present day
computers with a processor or many processes,
various kinds of memory and a cascade of read and write operations.
Now,
I think this is part of what is steered people the wrong way,
not so much the computational electronic picture of the material.
And I think that's an interesting topic to think about here at Google,
but the,
the more general picture of the physical and the earlier mechanistic conception,
uh,
I think has been a significant source of trouble here.
Instead,
we should think about the distinctive properties of cellular life,
the particular kinds of going on goings on within cells.
That's an aqueous environment and a Nano scale environment.
Everything is in water,
in solution.
This continual spontaneous activity and the way things get done within a shell
is by means of essentially a multitude of biased random walks.
So the physical itself is different in the sea and in cells.
Now,
I'm not saying that's itself enough to remove or mystery,
but I think it's important to think the right way,
thinking the right way about the biological basis of the mind as we think about
this problem.
And when animals moved up on land,
this is an animal has not yet moved up on land.
They took all this with them.
They hold up in this cells,
the chemistry of the sea,
where they came from.
Now,
as the title of my book suggests,
we are working towards the special role in this story of octopuses and other
cephalopods,
but we're not there yet.
Uh,
the next thing to think about is the overall shape of the history of animal
life.
Now lies in general forms the shape of a tree,
roughly speaking.
So from a single route,
a series of branching events,
usually with no rejoining extend to the present day,
there are branchings and then divergence.
This process began with single celled life.
We don't know the original forms,
but based on what we know about single celled organisms.
Now the picture to have in your mind is not little cells that are self
contained,
little islands,
but uh,
systems that are open to the world,
sensing and responding,
uh,
exhibiting behavior,
including even social behavior on a tiny scale.
Now,
animals are one branch of multicellular life.
And the first way to think about animals who say I one pretty big branch of the
tree of life,
a branch that comes off around 900 million years ago or so perhaps.
And in that transition to multicellular life,
the sensing and signaling that cells had been doing his whole organisms in the
unicellular state is now used to coordinate activities of cells within the new
collective entities that had arisen making possible coordinated and coherent
action.
So the social behavior of cells becomes the means for all animal action.
Now there's no fossil record of the very earliest stages,
the first stages of the history of animal life that we do have a fossil record
of,
uh,
from the Edm ackeren period.
Uh,
roughly 635 to 540 million years ago.
This is a photo of a fossil,
of a tip of a typical Ediacaran fossil in the South Australian museum.
And the,
it's the sort of round thing that is the likely animal fossil,
something that looks a little bit like a bathmat.
Um,
so life was very different back then.
Everything,
all animals with soft bodied and life also seems to have been fairly quiet.
This is a,
I think a gorgeous reconstruction of Ed ackeren life,
uh,
by the English artists,
John Civic.
And one of the distinctive things that this sort of illustration captures is the
fact that animals,
uh,
well,
it's not even clear which of these living things were animals,
but animals in particular don't seem to have had too much to do with each other.
Many of them probably didn't move around at all.
So that's the first stage.
And now I want to start to place all this into a larger historical context.
Also looking forward.
So there is a summary picture of part of the,
uh,
animal branch of the tree of life.
This is from the book.
So with all of these are tree pictures,
you should think of time as running up the screen and the first,
uh,
so we have a series of branchings giving rise to at the top various different
present day kinds of organisms.
Vertebrates there on the left mollusks including cephalopods,
which I'll talk about shortly,
arthropods,
including insects.
Then you get things like Jelly fish and sponges.
Um,
and the first,
well the next thing to note is that many of the deep branchings in animal
evolution took place in the EDL ackeren period.
That's when the sort of separations occurred.
Now here's another picture,
not from the book,
uh,
from another paper of mine.
What the orange band there represents is the fact that the deep historical
branchings giving rise to various present day groups,
those branchings took place in the EDL occurring at this time of very limited
interaction.
A particularly important animal living at that time might have looked something
like this.
This is a sort of little worm like creature.
There's no fossil record of it.
This is very much a sort of tentative reconstruction.
Uh,
but it was something like the first animal that had left right symmetry as part
of its body plan.
It had a left and right as well as a top and bottom.
And,
um,
this body plan evolved in the EDL ackeren.
Most of the animals that we're familiar with,
our bilateria animals,
they have that kind of left,
right plan was originally laid down in something like this.
This was probably a very small animal.
Um,
quite simple.
It did have a nervous system almost certainly,
but a simple nervous system most likely.
Um,
so on a slide like that,
we have that animal placed at its particular moment in the tree and everything
down stream,
uh,
sort of on each branch is a bilaterally symmetrical organism including ourselves
and animals,
animals like octopuses.
So the branchings occurred early before,
what's known as the Cambrin explosion.
Then in the Cambrian life changed dramatically rather than soft body animals
would look a bit like macaroons or bath mats.
You have animals that looked something like this.
You have hard parts,
spines clause.
You have complex sensory mechanisms,
especially complex eyes.
And it is very likely that this is when animals began to have much more to do
with each other,
especially as predators and prey.
From there,
you get lots of downstream evolution and this takes us through something that
can be roughly summarized with a picture like this.
Lots of animals come from this early bilateria and uh,
this early bilaterial lineage.
And in a few groups you have the evolution of lodge Brian's and complex
behavior.
You have firstly the evolution of large brains and complex behavior.
In our group,
in the vertebrates,
many vertebrates are like this,
especially in mammals and birds and in what we informally refer to as
invertebrates.
All the others,
you mostly have animals that have small nervous systems and relatively simple
behavior.
But with one big exception,
the cephalopods a group of mollusks.
Um,
here we have a lodge near the system,
one in the vertebrate brain,
sorry,
in the Vertebra Range,
roughly 500 million neurons in the case of an octopus and the most recent common
ancestor of you on one side and an octopus on the other with it's very large
[inaudible] system was that very simple,
warm light preacher living in the EDF 600 million years ago.
So what we really have is independent evolution from that point down,
two sides and something we can think of as two independent experiments,
evolutionary experiments in the,
in the,
uh,
origin of large nervous systems and complex brains.
So I cephalopod is what we were looking at the results of the one experiment
outside our line in the evolution of a large,
really large nervous system.
And I think of this consequently as the closest we'll ever come to meeting an
intelligent alien.
When I say that,
I mean the following.
If you think about what it would be like to meet an alien,
the big fact about an alien is that it's an intelligent form of life that has no
common ancestor with us at all.
Something from a totally separate evolutionary lineage,
an octopus,
you're certainly not like that,
but the common ancestor is so far away and probably quite simple.
And as a result,
most of what we see arose independently in the roughly 600 million years ago
since that common ancestor.
So what did we get on the other side?
Uh,
and why did we get it?
Well,
we get a mixture of similarities and differences from,
uh,
things like ourselves.
The most conspicuous similarity between a cephalopod and uh,
a vertebrate is the eye cephalopods independently evolved a camera eye.
So this is a giant cuddle fish,
which is the same kind of I as an octopus,
a camera I with a lens that focuses an image on a retina.
You also have various sophisticated kinds of learning.
And lastly,
something that was really the beginning of my own fascination with these
animals.
There's a kind of engagement,
uh,
that these animals display when you interact with them.
The first ones I came across myself would not octopuses but giant cuddle fish.
Like uh,
this guy here,
this animal was probably,
uh,
sort of between two and three feet long.
They're not small.
I was snorkeling near Sydney and saw under alleged something moving around,
went down and had a look at it.
And as I thought from the surface,
it was a large animal and something very active.
And the two striking,
the two most striking things about it were firstly the astounding array of
college changes that it was producing.
As I watched it,
these animals can change the entire color of their skin in much less than a
second.
And secondly,
the fact that this animal seem about as interested in me as I was in it,
there's a kind of a feeling of meeting you can have with these animals,
which is I take it unique when animal,
when a,
when a person meets another invertebrate.
And quite rare when we made any animal,
just to give you a sense of the capacity for college change,
these two photographs were taken a four seconds apart.
So a giant cuddle fish can completely transform it,
skin to that yellow in less than a second,
and then take it back to that reddish pattern,
uh,
a few seconds later.
And this image also gives you a sense of the fact that it's not just whole
colors that they can produce,
but very complex stripes and bands,
uh,
dynamic as well as static patterns as well.
So how did they come to be animals that could do these things?
Let's talk a little bit about the cephalopod brain and the kind of being that
these animals are.
So as I said,
there are roughly 500 million neurons in an octopus.
The number is not really known for cuddle fish,
but they may have even a slightly higher ratio of our brain weight to body
weight.
Then octopuses have the big difference between them and us is the fact that more
than half of the neurons in an octopus are not where you'd expect to find them
in the head,
but spread through the body,
especially within the arms themselves.
And each of the arms appears to have some degree of autonomy as a kind of quasi
agent.
Now how did this come to happen?
We can put some of it into context by looking at the,
the lies that will leave and history of this particular,
so here's a reconstruction of what,
uh,
an ancestor,
an early,
early nish ancestor of present day.
CEPHALOPODS might've looked like,
uh,
back in the palliate back in the Paleozoic.
This is a lodge shelled predator.
At some point in that it animal evolution,
the shells were abandoned and what you're left with was a body with a kind of
immense flexibility.
You should think by the way about an octopus arms or a cuddle fishes arms,
not so much his arms but really as kind of eight or 10 enormous lips and those
enormous multi shaped lips,
uh,
extremely useful things if you can control them.
But they are extremely difficult things to control.
Now in us when we move our joints,
give our movements guidance,
you don't have to tell your arm every detail about where to go in an octopus
with no joints and no hard parts at all.
The arm can be essentially any shape and length.
So you would either have to specify exactly,
uh,
the fine details of all its motions or gives the arm a little bit of freedom to
work out the details if it's motions itself.
And it does seem that there has been a sort of partial delegation of control,
uh,
to the arms of an octopus by evolution.
Each of them has a many senses.
Whenever an octopus touches you,
it's tasting you as well as feeling you'll shite.
And they seem to do,
at least they seem interested,
have determined that at least the details of many of their emotions themselves
and also engage in a kind of exploration on their own.
So here are a couple of photos that give you a sense of the contrast here.
So firstly we have uh,
two,
uh,
screenshots from the video in which this octopus is reaching aggressively for
another one.
And in a shot like this,
the arm seems very much like a sort of tool directed by the animal as a whole.
It's reaching with one arm for this guy.
Uh,
and in this case,
uh,
successfully,
successfully seizing it.
This kind of picture gives the opposite impression.
I don't have a video of this,
uh,
sequence,
unfortunately just a,
just an image,
but you're not the person that's sitting there doing nothing in particular.
And one of the arms,
the red area there indicates the extent of it has just kind of wandered off in a
way that looked to me as if it was apparently more or less self directed.
A kind of exploratory behavior by the arm on its own.
Now given all this and natural question to ask next is what might it be like to
be an octopus?
Is it like anything to be an octopus?
Um,
look,
I think these questions are,
of course very hard to answer.
I think the answer,
does it feel like something to be an octopus is yes.
The harder question is how to address rigorously,
um,
a problem of that kind.
Now the first thing to note,
I think is that a reasonable view has it that a certain kind of experience in
animals just comes with a certain degree of complexity in sensing and responding
and acting upon the world that runs deep in animal evolution.
Octopuses are exemplars of that kind of capacity.
Another more specific thing I think it's worth looking for is evidence of,
uh,
things like pain.
So lots of what might look superficially like pain related behaviors in various
animals,
especially invertebrates are probably,
or possibly quite misleading.
They may not be good indicators of felt pain of a kind of interior sensation of
the salt,
uh,
that comprises pain in us.
Um,
one.
So then the question arises,
how can you look for behavior that shows something non reflexive,
something that's indicative or suggestive,
at least that feels like something to be an animal of a certain kind in pain.
And one good example that's being looked at in several groups recently,
his wound tending,
you can ask the question,
which animals will tend to damage pot protect it from being touched by other
objects and stimuli.
Uh,
as,
as as time goes on,
we got an interesting series of shots of an octopus,
uh,
exhibiting pain related behavior.
This is a,
in some ways the sort of comical shot,
uh,
not so much to the octopus.
I think this was a large aggressive octopus who was trying to dominate a
particular site I'll talk about shortly.
And one of the things he did in his attempts to dominate was raise his rear end,
very high above his body in these sort of size displays.
And in one particular occasion where he raised his rear end very high,
uh,
fish came in and beat him really hard,
right on the end of his body there.
And you can see the fish biting these fish by the way,
are very unpleasant,
uh,
to buy.
Even if you're a person.
I've been bitten by them and it's,
uh,
it's not nice.
Uh,
the octopus behaved exactly like a person sort of with this very Staffold leap,
an arms carrying everywhere.
I was curious whether he would tend the wound.
He did not.
Instead he went,
uh,
back to beating up other octopus's.
So an octopus has sort of reasonably good evidence I think of various kinds of
subjective experience.
The special element and the question I think that's particularly intriguing
here,
concerns what kind of sense of self there might be in an animal of this kind and
how different that would be in an octopus ended in a more centralized neurally
centralized animal like ourselves.
So we can ask which activities and octopus engages in,
uh,
experienced as,
as my actions as offered by the individual as opposed to things that just happen
and are observed by the central animal,
uh,
by means of those semi agent like arms in a talk I gave last week.
I'm a Grad student at University of Pennsylvania,
uh,
made a suggestion instead of obvious in retrospect,
but I hadn't thought about it much before,
which is that,
well,
they need not be a single answer to this question.
It might be that when an octopus is doing is already sort of focused intentional
behavior like that reach.
And if I do,
I had there then as a kind of single agent like subject to the experience,
but that might sort of lapse or fall away and be replaced by a more distributed,
less self-like entity when you're seeing individual exploration by the arms.
So these are some of the questions that we'd like to ask.
A sort of mixture of,
uh,
philosophical and scientific questions about these animals and work is
continuing on this.
Um,
in the last part of this talk,
what I'll do is just show us some shots and some videos from a particular site.
A were,
a lot of these photos were taken and octopus site,
uh,
that we call AUC topless,
which is a written about in some detail in the book.
This is a site on the east coast of Australia.
Okay.
Here's the first video.
Oh,
here we go.
This just gives you a sense of what this site is like in on a sort of typical
day.
You've got a large number of shells on a shale bed and various octopuses who,
uh,
in residents and what's believed about octopuses in general is they're not very
social animals.
It's unusual for them to have to interact with each other in decent numbers.
But at this particular site in Australia that we study that essentially had to,
had to learn to get along.
The view we have is that it's a site where there's an abundance of food,
uh,
but a great scarcity of decent den sites and one particular area,
an area,
but there was perhaps seeded by a single human left object of unknown origin,
provided a kind of seed around which a crystal like growth occurred,
whereby octopus's came to live in large numbers.
And a lot of the time they engage in sort of mild controlled aggression.
Occasionally they engage in more intense aggression.
So this animal on the left here is in fact the octopus who is bitten on the rear
end by uh,
the fish we saw earlier.
And this is a sort of typical dice of him engaging in a series of fights where
he attempts to control access to this pretty large side,
the side about aside about the size of this stage.
And he's appeared to be able to far as we could tell to determine with some
reliability the sexes of individuals coming on and off the site.
And I tried to exclude other males so we engaged in a series of fights and um,
and much of the time did succeed in excluding them a feature that's also unique
it,
this slide is a kind of signaling,
this is the kind of display or talked about briefly earlier,
we're animals who are aggressive will go up very large and dark,
maximizing that darkness and size.
And if you look closely at the animal who is about to chase,
you'll see this animal has gone Pale.
But more specifically,
you'll see that it has done a color change such that half of its body,
the half facing the attacking octopus is a kind of high contrast models sort of
color.
And the other half of its body facing away is a kind of simple camouflage.
Now we're not sure exactly why that is.
The,
the sort of high contrast pattern on the side facing,
uh,
has a role in various cephalopod,
behaviors as a kind of,
uh,
w w 400 called a d mathic display.
The idea is you show this to a Predator and it might start all the predator.
It's possible as being sort of pressed into service as an attempt to,
uh,
in a few tile way startled this oncoming octopus.
However,
many individuals produce fifth display when they're not trying to run away,
but trying to kind of,
uh,
um,
creep onto the slide under the guise of another animal in a nonaggressive
manner.
So we suspect that it may have been pressed into service as a kind of indicator
of non aggressive tendencies,
uh,
in these animals.
And then the question arises,
is this something that isn't a widespread,
but here the two unseen feature of this behavior across the species?
Or is it something that just developed in the particular peculiar social media
of this site?
Another thing that's an unusual feature of this site is what we've come to call
a kind of high five behavior.
So this octopus,
uh,
on the right there is moving across towards the others.
And as it goes,
they'll often be a kind of,
I originally called this boxing,
but now I realize I was being too pugilistic in my metaphors.
And it might be a kind of slap of recognition or something like indication of
roles on the site that animals do by a sort of just sort of jabbing at each
other with the ums.
This is a picture of me at the site,
uh,
try to fix a camera while a whole bunch of stuff goes on around me,
none of which I'm able to see going on.
So we only sometimes successfully look at them.
Uh,
they often quite successfully,
uh,
observe us.
This is a octopus inspecting one of our go pro cameras.
Uh,
possibly as a preliminary to taking it apart.
So I'll stop there.
Happy to take a few questions.
Uh,
I think you'll agree these are truly a fascinating and stunning animals.
Okay.
Thanks for the talk.
It was very,
very cool to see that.
Um,
so probably the most remarkable thing about the chameleon
experiment with intelligence,
I would say is our incredible memories.
Um,
it's hard,
difficult to imagine what my sense of self would be like without,
um,
that,
that kind of memory.
What kind of memory to the cephalopods have,
there's some interesting new work on this in cuddle fish,
which is interesting,
particularly in a continuity's between the human and this case.
Uh,
so in,
in the case of humans,
this sort of a standard distinction between forms of memory,
um,
the sort of memory of how to do things,
procedural memory,
what's called semantic memory,
memory of facts.
You know,
the fact that Paris is the capital of France and episodic memory is memory of
what happened to you of experiences and the kind of memory that you were
describing is very sort of distinctive to human experiences.
Is that kind?
So a good question is which animals might have something like episodic memory
memory,
not just of facts,
you know,
where things are,
but of what experiences I had when I was in that place.
And recently some work that's been used to study episodic memory or rather
episodic like memory in birds has been also applied to cuddle fish.
Uh,
and when I went describe all the details of the experimental design,
which was very clever and subtle,
but the upshot of it was that it appears that cuddle fish do have the ability to
remember,
not just facts,
like,
you know,
this food can be found there,
but facts of the form.
I was at this location and hour ago and eight or I was at this other location
two hours ago and didn't eat.
So a sense of,
I kind of,
uh,
not just sort of facts about the world,
but facts about what I have done in way I have been.
So,
I mean,
this I find,
especially in Thai thing,
because things like this,
there's just no chance that was present in the common ancestor of us in these
animals.
Uh,
so independently the same kind of sense of a self behaving in time appears to
have arisen in several different lines.
Great.
Thank you.
What do we know about the visual processing in these animals?
You said that the IRS and the IRS quite similar to the human eye.
Yea,
it does.
It does the animal have a similar organ stimulating,
organized visual Cortex?
Not Similarly in general.
Once you get past the eye,
everything becomes different in these,
in these animals.
I'm not that knowledgeable about the neuro physiology of a vision in octopuses.
I can certainly tell you where to look.
The,
the lab,
one of the labs that specializes in this is Benny Harkness lab at Hebrew
University in Jerusalem.
Uh,
they,
they're probably the leading lab,
uh,
with respect to the project of trying to work out.
You know,
how different the organizational properties are of an octopus,
his brain,
ours.
And one thing that they're looking at and have sort of made some claims about is
the idea that with within our mat,
within our brains you have quite a number of instead of map like structures
where the,
the sort of sensory array on the body maps to sort of adjacent or you know,
neighbor related neurons in the brain and that seems to be absent in octopuses
and you might think are right.
That has some link to the idea that uh,
there's too many degrees of freedom to control centrally.
So you leave that stuff to the oms or it might have some other explanation.
I don't know.
But he's pipe is,
we'd be the ones to look at.
Thank you.
It's really nice to see an actively researching scientist,
not deflationists about subjective experience.
It's pretty refreshing.
But I just wanted to say,
um,
you were getting at you know,
are very linear view on what conscious experiences like as potentially clouding
our view on like what it can be and how to fit it into a scientific world
worldview.
But you didn't really flesh out,
like what sort of future research program you had in mind for the types of like
different organizations of say,
like see like cells,
um,
for the future of fitting subjective experience into the scientific kind of
Canon.
So what,
what sort of research program for solving the Chaunra style hard problem do you
envision?
Okay,
that's a very big question indeed.
Uh,
and my answer would be sort of so many pronged.
It's sort of hard to organize it in a brief,
a reply.
But let me say a couple of things is very quickly.
One is I think that with respect to the sorts of challenges that people like
Charmaz,
uh,
make some of that should be treated in a more critical way.
And we say,
no,
this,
you know,
this kind of barrier is not real.
Or this problem for a materialist view is not real.
So I think a first move that one should make is to reorient our thinking about
the problem in a way that makes,
that's more critical about the,
the sort of unimaginable separability of the mental and the physical,
uh,
the basis for the arguments a of Charmaz and others.
So criticized that then choose the right thing to explain.
And I think the right thing to explain,
uh,
is not sort of consciousness as the sort of first target or what philosophy is
often referred to as Qualia.
The kind of rule feel of experience.
But uh,
subjectivity,
that's the right target.
You know,
how is it that some physical systems can comprise subjects that have a point of
view?
Once you understand that and where they came from,
I think it will be possible to explain subjective experience as something that
happens to subjects.
Now.
How can we give a scientific rode into the understanding of subjectivity in a
sense that's relevant,
uh,
to that,
question.
Um,
uh,
you know,
here I think there are lots of things,
lots of things to think about.
I mean,
giving a talk at Google,
it's very tempting to say something about attempts to come up with artificial
systems that are relevant.
And,
um,
I think what evolution had to do that was a big deal in this area was tight,
you know,
clausy autonomous selves that consents and signal and interact in certain ways
and have a kind of subject like status in a very minimal sense on their own and
coordinate them such that the subject,
the sort of protos subjectivity of those parts becomes sort of,
subsumed might not be quite the right word,
but it'll do for now into the subjectivity,
into the subjectivity of the collective that results.
Um,
I think classical AI did not think about the problem like that at all.
And even contemporary robotics tends to start from a more sort of straight
forwardly centralized organization.
And I certainly think it will be intriguing to sort of think about the problem
via the same path by which evolution thought about the problem,
which is,
uh,
unity in call activity with respect to systems of that con,
I think.
Thanks.
Great Talk.
Um,
so yeah.
Oh,
sorry.
That's fine.
Please go ahead.
Okay,
well good.
Yeah,
sure.
Um,
I,
uh,
a lot of what I've been reading about intelligent from sort of a neuroscience
point of view seems to me to lead into direction of saying that,
uh,
intelligence as we understand it is,
is sort of irreducibly social.
I mean the,
I think the signaling and,
and,
uh,
the signaling aspect and this,
the idea of a sense of self coming out of a model of,
of,
of others.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so I'm intrigued because it seems that that these animals are capable of,
of very,
very complex signaling,
but also you said they're not very social.
So I wonder what,
how much do you think their intelligence is social is engaged in signaling and,
and,
and sensing the other other animals?
I think for the most part,
cephalopods are a lesson pushing against those highly socialized conceptions of
intelligence that are very popular in many,
uh,
many theoretical domains at the moment.
Um,
so if,
you know,
if you,
I mean as a,
as a philosopher,
much of the time there are some philosophers who emphasize the sort of to and
fro and sociality and there are some philosophers who emphasize the richness of
the individual's experience and of particularity and cephalopods are sort of
with the,
with the second group there with William James,
a sort of individualistic style.
Um,
and um,
I think that's just something we learned from them.
We learned that,
um,
by means some kind of combination of the challenges of living the lives they
live,
uh,
where they're soft bodied there pray for anything of a decent size in the sea.
They're also predators.
They have to get around,
they have to be continually exploring and looking for food.
Um,
and with the bodies that are both so rich with possibility but so hard to
control.
I think we learned that that's enough just to build a very big and complex
nervous system.
Once you have that big and complex nervous system,
it appears that if you put a bunch of them together in an unusually high density
setting,
they'll,
you know,
here on going beyond what I can back up scientifically.
So I'm being very speculative.
I think a lot of the signaling behaviors that we see at AWC topless,
the site in Australia,
uh,
are a kind of improvised sociality.
I think the animal sort of work out a way with their general cleverness to
interact in ways that are not to sort of destructive and chaotic.
So I think they,
I think there are sort of a case on that side,
just what we're talking about,
the ways in which they push against the familiar.
Why is it talking about or thinking about the advantages in evolutionary terms
of having a large brain and high intelligence.
The other weird thing about these animals is their lives are so short and
octopus is dead usually within two years.
Uh,
which is astounding.
so in two years they kind of rush through the early stages and acquire quite a
large body in many cases.
Even the giant Pacific Octopus,
which is,
you know,
several hundred pounds of octopus.
Um,
they can live off into about four years.
But that's about it.
And that's the biggest octopus species known.
No one knows the lifespan of a giant squid,
you know,
the really colossal squid,
but it's thought to be of the same kind of order of five years or so.
So they rush through their lives and that would normally be thought to be
something that tells against the advantage of developing a large Brian and all
that learning.
And you've got no time to put it to any use.
So it just compounds the,
it compounds the puzzle in many ways.
Great.
Thanks.
Yes,
thank you for this very interesting talk.
So what do you think about the correlation between parenting and intelligence?
That's because Octopi,
do you have kind of parenting,
not,
not as the sot that should help
parenting.
We do care about where young
bought the eggs.
Yeah.
So once this is exactly the right sort of next puzzle to sort of mention after
the previous gentleman's questions.
So in many animals sort of smart,
you have significant parental care.
And the guidance of the next generation along the first steps with octopus's in
general mentioned an exception in a moment or a couple of exceptions in a
moment.
The general pattern is for the the female octopus,
um,
lay some eggs and she tends and broods them and fans them to get exactly the
right level of oxygen in the water that they're interacting with and the eggs
hatch and the larvae float away as plankton and that's it.
And she never sees them again.
So there's care in a sense of,
you know,
the eggs are not abandoned.
Cuddle fish eggs by the way are abandoned.
So the female cuddle fish lays eggs often on a ledge on the,
on the underside of the ledge and then just goes off.
And those eggs will hatch.
They're much more,
they're larger and better provision than octopus eggs and then a bit more
robust.
But when they hatch,
you know,
the,
the parents are long gone,
uh,
dead in fact.
And with octopus's is a bit more care but not care that you would think would
help with the sort of intellectual side of life very much.
Because once the eggs hatch,
they,
the larvae just become plankton.
Now there are a few exceptions where the larvae may at least settle locally.
They,
the,
the larvae are larger when they,
uh,
when the eggs hatch and don't just float away and become plankton.
Not very much is known about them.
There are a few sort of larger egg,
Dr Purses.
But even in that,
I think in general the picture is if you're an octopus from the day that your
hatching from the egg,
you're pretty much on your own and your days are numbered.
Yup.
So you mentioned the three structure of life lineage and you mentioned that in
some cases there are junctions.
I wonder if you could mention an example of this,
right?
So once you get to animals,
genuine junctions,
10 10,
not to occur,
but in single celled life.
So in bacteria you have a quite different shape.
I mean the tree,
the tree metaphor,
the tree model doesn't apply particularly well to bacteria,
um,
that continually exchanging bits and pieces of DNA in a kind of freeway.
Uh,
the eukaryotic cells that make up our bodies are the products of an event where
one,
I'm old,
you know,
ancient prokaryotic cell essentially swallowed and other,
and the two of them came to live as a unit.
So that,
that's a kind of merging in the tree where you know,
all the cells in your body are descended from emerging event that took place
probably perhaps something like 1.8 billion years or so ago.
Uh,
so do you think about the tree of life in a more exact way?
You should think that it's a,
it's a network.
The network in its old and unicellular domains or regions has a sort of somewhat
haphazard,
not really tree like that more complex.
And in some groups,
especially animals,
the thing sort of resolves into a more definite tree where you have to weigh
branchings and,
and as few or no,
not none,
but fewer,
no rejoining.
So the the full pictures is,
it's not quite a tree,
but we animals,
we form a pretty good tree.
Okay.
It's time for one more.
If anyone would like to
hip hop.
So you had an illustration of the common ancestor of the octopus and mammals?
Yeah.
From my perspective,
when I look at an octopus,
it seems to have a lot of similarities with mammals just in terms of the level
of advancement and complexity and some things like the,
you mentioned the design of the eye are quite similar.
Yup.
How much of that do you think was like latent in the DNA versus how much of that
was truly independent because it was required in the same way,
you know?
Do you think that there were independent mutations in the DNA that were
independently selected for,
or
it's a very good question and the words you used Leighton,
I think is exactly the right that's,
that's the right way to ask the question.
So you have some similarities of design in the present,
coming from something that looks very different in the past and there's a school
of thought in biology that I think would answer your question with a kind of
emphatic kiss then say,
oh yeah,
right.
They look very different.
But there was a kind of architecture that was kind of lightened in a way in the
first bilaterally symmetrical animals with a certain kind of head to tail axis,
a certain organization of nerve,
the relationship between nervous system and the rest.
And you know,
you should think of the subsequent unfolding down the two lines as just a kind
of,
you know,
the variations on a theme in a way.
And a theme that was set down early.
That's one kind of school of thought I'm describing as a bit metaphorically I
think.
I think it's clear in this case then as another and in some ways more
traditional school of thought that says,
look,
evolution can do anything.
It pretty much once with with with bodies and you started with something very
simple and um,
the fact that you have certain similarities here and here means that natural
selection,
just five and similar things.
And there were mutations occurring quite independently,
quite different,
uh,
in character that built a similar structure.
Now in the case of having an eye with a lens,
the second view is certainly right.
So there's no sense in which the eye lens was latent in,
uh,
in the common ancestor and octopus lenses and vertebrate lenses are built from
different staff.
They have a different role.
So,
um,
one distorts and one moves.
So camera lenses don't distort.
They move.
Uh,
some animal lenses distort the,
you know,
the change shape and some of them move.
Um,
but the presence of an eye at all in the animal forget the lens and the
particular structure.
But just whether you have light sensitive things,
roughly where they are.
Plenty of biologists think I,
that was probably laid down,
you know,
and,
and it's not something that was independently invented.
It's something that was laid down one time.
So,
I mean,
I,
my expertise such as it is,
is I can't give us a richer answer the question than that because the,
this,
what's you're putting your finger on there is a part of biology which is
intensely and actively debated and there are different reasonable positions.
Okay.
It's about five to natural to wrap up right about now.
Thanks.